[Music]
you
hello friends welcome to this last
lecture on the course on introduction to
cognitive psychology now over the past
twelve weeks we have been dealing with
several areas of cognitive psychology
starting with introduction to cognitive
psychology the chapters on perception
attention then the chapter on memory
various forms of memory then into
language and thought thinking process
problem solving reasoning and
decision-making ending finally with this
is in making so this last lecture I have
dedicated to basically summing up what
we did in this 12 weeks so what I will
do in this particular lecture is briefly
get back to each section that we did
along this 12 weeks and review what we
did in all of these lectures and
basically also sort of refresh you into
what each topic that we wanted to do or
that covered so basically it's a review
kind of a lecture and it will be very
very brief every free touching into our
topics that were content of each lecture
for each week so the lecture was
designed in basically four modules the
total scores of cognitive psychology
comprised of four modules and within
these modules we had different different
lectures each module had two to three
subtopics and they had their individual
lectures and all of them comprises two
packet of 30 lectures which then was
divided into a 12-week period referring
back to what is cognition so what is
cognition basically cognition is a
mental activity and so committee
psychology with it studies how these
mental events or mental representations
which are basically the representation
of any event or any object in the
external world how they are manipulated
and studied and so in this course on
cognitive psychology what we tend to do
is study how these manipulations are
maintained
is done by the mind or the brain and so
that is what we will do in this whole
lecture there's an outward or an outline
of this particular review lecture so
basically this course already psychology
comprises a set of four modules the
first module that we did had two
lectures onto it and the module was
called introduction to the study of
cognitive psychology and it had lectures
on the history of the cognitive
psychology and also on the methodology
with it in module two we covered some of
the basic cognitive processes which are
applied on to mental events on to mental
representations and the cognitive
processes that we studied in our in this
particular course was basically
perception and attention so we will be
then evaluating these two or studying or
reviewing these two cognitive processes
and also I think we redid memory onto it
the third module was basically
organization of knowledge so the first
two modules basically tell you the first
model basically focuses on what is
cognition and what is cognitive
knowledge and what is the background of
cognitive psychology the history of
cognitive psychology and how does it
develop what are the research
methodologies in it and that kind of a
thing the second module covered on two
basic cognitive processes how an input
is taken and this input which is taken
from the various senses and organs how
they are converted into meaningful
organizations or into knowledge or
mental representations so basically it
is the pre-processing it is those
processes those cognitive processes or
those cognitive work benches where draw
information which is captured through
our primary senses they are pre
processed before meaning is generated
out of it in module 3 we looked at
organization of knowledge so given the
fact that the basic cognitive processes
are able to extract information from the
raw input that is given up by the senses
these input has to be safe somewhere at
to be kept somewhere in in a particular
format which is called mental
representation and so this third module
were basically focused on to how this
mental representation is stored and
where it is stored into what is the
format and how it is accessed what are
the limits of it and so on and so forth
so is basically the organization of
knowledge into the human brain and the
fourth module was when the knowledge is
stored once the knowledge has been
attained by the basic cognitive
processes and they have been stored or
organized into the memory how are they
accessed and what how are meaning
generated out of it or how is this
knowledge successfully used is what the
fourth module looked into and so what
we'll do from now on from the next slide
onwards we will take up each of these
module one by one and then explain to
you what we covered there and how it
relates to the next module or the next
chapter so under module 1 in the week 1
what we did was we looked at the history
and the study of human cognition so the
first week which first and second week
which are part of the first module there
we looked at briefly at the history of
cognitive psychology how does karate
psychology come into being what does it
study what are its proponents what are
the basic principles governing cognitive
psychology and after that we also looked
at the various research methodologies
which are available for doing cognitive
psychology for someone who's interested
in cognitive psychology what are the
research methodologies that you're going
to do so we started a journey into this
section of history and study of human
cognition by studying or by basically
reading about the basic debates and
philosophy for example the debate about
nativism and empiricism or the debate
about mind body problem not these
debates about empiricism an atavism or
mind body problem or nature-nurture
issue they describe or they form the
basic core of their cognitive psychology
comes in because it was the philosophers
before the coming of the real science of
psychology that they wanted to study
what is the difference between the mind
and the soul and what I wanted to study
what is the mind and they were interest
these philosophers are the ones who were
interested or on how human beings do
things that they do so they had no idea
what the mind is or the brain composed
of and at that point of time they wanted
to study why individuals why humans are
different and so they proposed these
theories now for example the empiricism
and nativism theory they emphasizes one
of it emphasizes the role of heredity in
producing knowledge or in gaining
knowledge and the other emphasizes the
fact that human beings are born with a
blank state of mind but later in life
through experience they develop
knowledge so knowledge is not something
which is passed on from heredity it
comes on through the interaction with
people interaction with the environment
so these debates basically move forward
the idea of what is the basis of
cognitive psychology further on we went
ahead and studied the basic schools of
psychology we looked at the basic
schools of psychology schools like
structuralism functionalism Gestalt
school the school of behaviorism and the
cognitive school and all these schools
what they did was they provided us the
basis or the reason how cognitive
psychology developed as a field so these
schools the study of these schools gave
us an idea of what is cognitive
psychology what is the content of
cognitive psychology and how these
schools mattered in the coming after the
field of cognitive psychology especially
the cognitive revolution the idea of
qualitative regulation or the creative
school they for the first time
introduced the fact that behaviorism
believed that stimulus response is how a
particular behavior is related to a
particular kind of a stimulus and so
behaviorism believed that there is
nothing called the mind there is nothing
called the brain there is nothing called
mental activities or mental events and
so each response that a person does each
behavior the person does is directly
related to the upcoming stimulus or to
any external or internal stimulus and so
for the first time when the cognitive
revolution comes in people started
focusing on the Oh in SR and so the over
introduced which basically meant that
stimulus s do not directly respond to
directly
response attack reproduce behavior but
rather there was an organism or there
were a human mind which controlled
responses so stimulus responses were not
kind for mechanistic rule but in an
organism or a human mind controlled the
response and this is for the first time
the karate Revolution produced the idea
or the cognitive school of thought
produced the idea that the human mind is
responsible for producing all kind of
inputs further on we looked at the
definition of what mental events are we
looked at what are mental
representations for example what mental
representations are mental
representations are basically
representations or these are encoding of
any event or any person place or thing
into the human mind so anything that
happens in the external environment has
to be steady in the brain in a
particular format in the mind in a
particular format and that about mental
representations are and so these
representations are have a format and a
particular kind of encoding so the
format describes what the mental
representation in which way it is
encoded and the content of mental
represented describe what it wants to
say and we explained it in that chapter
in terms of both the special as well as
the pictorial definitions or the special
and the propositional kind of
representations of how particular
information can be represented in the
human brain so that is what we did in
this section further than that we also
looked at several other schools of
thought or several other paradigms which
went ahead and described how cognitive
psychology progress for example we
looked at the evolutionary school we
looked at the connectivist school the
information processing paradigm and so
on and so forth in addition to that we
also looked at why study the brain if
you want to study soccer cognitive
psychology and the reasoning that was
provided there was because study of the
brain for studying for very psychology
providers not only identify ability
effects but also it gives us the
adequacy effect it basically means that
studying the brain will tell us what
functions are responsible for or what
kind of mental activities are a small
related to what kind of brain
activations and that way our relation
can be mashed up in the second week we
went ahead and studied theories and
researches in human cognition in this
particular lecture we looked at the
various research methodologies that has
been used for creating or studying
cognition and the three primary research
methodologies that we studied was just
the methodology of behavioral approach
the correlational approach the casual
approach and the modelling approach now
in the behavioral approach we primarily
use three different type of measurements
the first measurement being the
measurement of accuracy the second
measurement being the measurement of
reaction time the third measurement
being the measurement of judgment and
these three measurement or these three
criterias can be used to the to measure
or to design experiments in cognitive
psychology besides the behavioral
methodology for studying cognitive
psychology there is also something
called a correlational method of
studying cognitive psychology or
cognitive phenomena or mental events and
this correlational methodology uses the
input from devices like such as the
electrons of the graphs or the mental
the MDG the magnet or insula graphs for
the the magnitude in circular graph of
the electroencephalograph they provide
us brief idea about what happens at the
brain when a particular mental event is
being processed or particular mental
event is being taken care of in addition
to the eg & M eg there are devices which
are called the positive emotions
tomography
damar eyes NF MRIs all of which provides
us what happens or tells us what happens
at the brain when a certain mental
activity is happening and so they gave
us kind of a correlational structure so
if some change in a mental event happens
correlational change or us simultaneous
change also happens in the brain and
these equipments provide us the idea of
what happens into the brain when a
particular cognitive activity happens
beside that explain to you the causal
network where we looked at three
methodologies the methodology of using
neuro physiological studies in which
patients were studied for finding out
what are the reasons for or how is brain
related to the particular cognitive
activity also looked at an equipment
called the TMS which can specifically
inhibit certain areas of the brain and
study how a particular area is related
to a particular mental activity and a
third way of using drugs or certain kind
of inhibitors neurotransmitter
inhibitors for studying or inhibiting
certain kind of brain region and
studying the function of that brain
region in addition to that the last
method that we use in this particular
section was the method of modeling in
which what we studied is there are
different computer models can be
generated and these models are two in
nature the box model and the neural
network model and both of these models
can be used to basically represent the
mental activity of how a mental activity
gets processed or how a mental event
gets processed so this is what we did in
the first two week and this is what we
studied in the first two chapters in
victory we looked at object perception
and recognition and so in this
particular section in object perception
and recognition what we looked on - or
what we studied was we looked at both
the classical and the gestalt approach
to perception and in the classical
approach it was said that there is
something called distal and proximal
stimulus and that is how perception
really happens so basically the idea of
this chapter was to study how
perceptions are developed or how
information which is passed on from the
sensation that is taken into the brain
and that is coded into the brain to the
process which is called perception and
so two theories were studied the
classical theory said that whenever
something and we basically studied the
visual perception we specifically
studied the visual perception although
at a later point we also described a
little bit of auditory perception but we
focused ourselves into visual perception
because that is the easiest sense to
study and so in terms of visual
perception we studied the classical
theory which says that there is
something called a proximal stimulus and
there is something called a distal
stimulus and these two stimulus is
interact together to form images onto
the retina which are further carried on
to the specialized object recognition
area or the brain in the occipital lobe
and from
meaning is generated we also looked at
certain theories of other object
perception for example the bottom up in
the top-down theories now within the
bottom of theories we looked at
something called the template matching
theory we also looked at something
called the feature analysis theory and
the prototype matching theory the
difference being that in template
matching theory it proposes that there
are huge number of temples in the brain
and that helps someone in recognizing a
particular object in the external field
of vision whereas the feature analysis
theory goes ahead and says that object
recognition is not based on these kind
of human templates the reason being that
so many templates cannot be stored in
the brain so it is instead of the number
of templates stored in the brain it is
the pattern it is the feature of a
particular object which is of use for
doing object recognition whereas the
prototype theory says that nine of the
feature analysis truly not nor the
template matching theories enough
because so many templates cannot be
stored in the brain and neither the
feature analysis Theory tells us what a
feature could be so the prototype model
says that human brain creates a
prototype and this prototype is what
actually goes ahead and helps us in
doing bottom-up processing so what is
what am i processing in bottom-up
processing we start with the very basic
knowledge we fought with the very basic
inputs which are coming from the visual
senses and from there we try to do the
object perception in a position to the
so coming from general to specific or
looking at a number of information which
is out there and combining the all this
information to understand what an object
is is called bottom-up process so it is
from bottom of the pyramid going towards
top of the pyramid in a position to the
bottom of process there is something
called the top-down process and in the
top-down process we actually studied how
the experience past experiences of human
beings help us in object on
identification in within the adoption
process we studied something called
perceptual learning studied change
blindness and word security effect all
of these displays that the human
experience is enough in creating
perception and lastly in this section on
perception recognition of the perception
cognition we study something called
direct perception which is the theory
which is directly opposing to the theory
of classical perception and gestalt
perception so what does the theory say
it says that human beings don't need to
do anything onto the incoming stimulus
rather the incoming stimulus is has
enough information the incoming light
from an object in the external field has
enough information when it falls into
the retina and that is enough to create
any kind of any perception which is
needed in this fourth week we ventured
on to the chapter on attention and
attentional processes and cognition and
so in this second section we
specifically select studied selective
attention although so what is attention
basically attention is focusing yourself
into a particular information so
focusing your senses into a particular
information and we looked into the
selective attention within the selective
attention we discussed several theories
which are our selective attention for
example one of the theory that we
discussed was the filter theory we also
looked at an attachment theory of
attenuation we looked at the late
selection theory we looked at kanbans
theory and schema theory now all these
theories differ from each other in
certain ways for example plate selection
theory says that the bottleneck that is
there in terms of attention is not at
the start of attentional process but at
a later part of an attentional process
whereas the filter theory suggests that
whatever calls whatever information
falls under the perceptual system it is
filtered right there at the beginning of
the attentional process the blade
selection theory says that this
filtering happens at the end of it and
there are several reasoning or there are
several line of experimentation which
has been provided for the support of
these theories similarly the attenuation
theory says that nothing is filtered out
in an attentional filter what happens is
only the volume of information which is
available is toned down similar to that
there is cannulas theory which talks
about alertness and certain
propositional requirements and certain
other kind of a motivational needs which
all come together to decide how
attention is focused on to something and
the schema theory is direct victory
which basically goes I didn't say is
that whatever is not perceived is never
looked on - and that is the reason why
attention is an all-or-none kind of a
phenomena beside that we also looked at
how attention becomes on what conditions
attentions become automatic and how this
autumn a city of attention actually
helps people it was the end of the
chapter we discuss something called the
psychological refractory period it
basically suggests or which basically is
the time gap or the time required for
somebody to process to incoming
informations so if two incoming
informations are given to someone who's
processing up already
so two incoming informations occur
simultaneously to a person this person
will be delayed in replying to the
second information and this delay is
what is called the psychological
refractive period in the fifth week we
looked at encoding and retrieving of
memory traces and so in this particular
week we looked at what is human memory
so we discussed the popular modal model
of human memory which talks about
sensory memory then the short-term
memory and long-term memory beside that
we also looked at different kind of
sensory memories which are available for
example the iconic memory and the
equation brain and also the haptic
memory we looked at what is STM and we
looked at the various features of STM
before that we also discussed in detail
what are the features of an icon and
what are the features of an echo and how
they are distinguished and we discuss
several experiments of what in equal
what an icon is of a sensory memory in
terms of the short-term memory we looked
at what is short-term memory what is
this capacity what it can do what it
cannot do part of the kind of forgetting
that it it happens from short-term
memory the coding in short-term memory
which is basically in terms of the the
semantics in acoustic coding we also
looked at how forgetting happens we
discussed two experiments on Ron and
Peterson in Vega Norman of how
forgetting actually happens in
short-term maybe towards the end of it
this section we looked at what something
called working memory so working memory
which is an improvement on short-term
memories and we looked into that so what
is basically working memory it is an
ruminal short-term memory whereas the
preposition goes that short-term memory
is a store which is non dynamical in
nature working memory proposes a store
which is more dynamically nature in the
sense that it has three different parts
it has something called a central
executive there's something called a
phonological loop it has something
called a visual spatial sketchpad and so
as against the fact the short-term
memory is not directly connected to long
term memory it cannot directly interact
with long term memory working memory at
all points of time are connected to the
long term memory so something called the
episodic wafer and I provided you
reasons of why this improvement was
necessary and what this improvement
actually meant so this was the first
part of selection in the second part of
lecture we looked at what is long-term
memory so in the first part of the
lecture we looked at what is STM what is
sensory memory the coatings are
forgetting the variables which are
affecting it and so on and so forth in
the second part of this lecture on
lecture 5 between lecture 5 and lecture
6 there was another section on long-term
memory where we look specifically on
what is long-term memory and how does
Kody happen in long-term memory so
basically the coding that happens in
long-term memory is semantic in nature
we also looked at the various forgetting
to use of long term memory and some
popular theories that we discussed was a
decay theory the interference Theory the
poor encoding theory and so on and so
forth
we also discussed what is the capacity
of long-term memory and so what it can
store how it can store what it can
process and what it cannot we discuss
two basic types of recoil method two
basic types of the tribal method from
long-term memory so if an information is
stored in long-term memory how is it
pushed back or how is it
Detra back and we discussed recall and
recognition being the two method of
retrieving information from long-term
memory recall being a method in which a
person has to remember from his memory
and write something back in recognition
some distractors are provided with the
correct answer and the person has to
identify the correct answer and
discriminate it from the
distractor so these are the two methods
of each other we also looked at
something called context effect and
state effects in long-term memory and we
showed how varying the context and
keeping the context same while encoding
in long-term memory and while they
travel in long-term memory the benefit
of memory is seen we also looked at the
physiological state the person days or
the mood the person is also helps in
better remembering of long-term memory
or worse remembering of long-term memory
we also here included the distinctions
of long-term memory in terms of the
declarative and procedural types so here
itself we saw how long-term memory is
defined in two parts the relative in the
procedural type in the declarative type
the old memories are crap which are
conscious in nature whereas in the
process of procedural type the implicit
memories are kept and we also discussed
how this declarative memory is further
broken down into its semantic and
episodic form and how the procedural
memories are broken down into its
classical conditioning habit and priming
in several other forms of procedural
memory so this is what we did there at
the end of this section we looked at
reconstruction of memory or how high
memory reconstruction is there how false
memory is formed and what is called
eyewitness testimony so basically what
we understand is that memory is never
true whatever we store has some form of
reconstruction onto it and so at the end
of section we looked at the experimenter
by lock test and several of the
experiments for example the DRAM
paradigm the DS door dragon egg timer
paradigm which basically shows us that
the memory the information which is kept
in memory is never accurate it is never
a representation of the events that have
happened and it is always a
reconstruction which is there and we try
to focus here or we try to tell here I
try to evaluate and show to you that
memory is never true it is all it is
always a reconstruction of the the
information or the manipulation of
information which was originally stored
in the next section of memory in general
knowledge what we did was we started the
section with an introduction to the
distinction between the episodic in the
semantic form so in the last chapter we
saw how long-term memory is broken down
into
it's declarative and procedural format
and within the procedural format we have
the cementing in the episodic store so
this section started by distinguishing
between what is episodic memory and what
is semantic memory and this section was
particularly dedicated to semantic
memory so semantic memory is that memory
which holds in knowledge information of
all the fact and things like that daily
routine events all those information are
stored into something called a semantic
store or semantic a part of the
long-term memory whereas in the episodic
form or in the episodic part of the
long-term memory we have events life
events which are stored and there are
several different types of episodic
memory which are there and so our
Associated memories for example there's
something for the autobiographical
memory there is something called the
flashbulb memory and we discussed that
at the end of the last section in this
particular section we looked at memory
for general knowledge which is semantic
memory so we looked at what is semantic
memory and what are the different models
of semantic memory the particular models
that we discussed in this particular
chapter was the hierarchical semantic
model there are the HSM and the HSM what
we found out is that the various
knowledge is which are stored in
semantic memory they are connected to
hierarchies or they're connected by
something called nodes and pointers and
so a new information has a superordinate
node and superordinate the way
information is coded is in terms of
categories and concepts and so these
concepts and categories are how
information is stored on to one another
and this the hierarchical semantic
Network model basically explained how
information this general information is
stored as hierarchies within the
semantic memory beside the hierarchical
semantic model we also looked at
something called the feature comparison
model which was an improvement on the
hierarchical semantic model and said
that since the there was some problem
the criticism with a director semantic
model in terms of verification of
sentences verification of information
which is present in higher the semantic
model the feature analysis model says
that information is not stored in terms
of hierarchies rather it is stored in
terms of feature analysis so based on
the core features and based on the
characteristic defining and the
characteristic features information is
actually stored into this hierarchical
networks or information is stored into
the semantic memory we also looked at
something called the spreading
activation model which says that
whenever one concept or whenever one
particular information bit is excited
this information this excitation or this
kind of a retrieval is spread on two
concepts which are related to each other
and how multiple concepts which are
somehow related to each other are
activated when particular node is
activated so how does the spreading
happens or how does energy spread from
one node to the other node so these are
some of the models that we study into
and beside that we also studied the AC T
model the Andersons is it the model
which talks about three different kind
of memory system in the working memory
system the procedural memory in the
declarative memory and what this model
said is declarative memory is entirely
different from priscila memory in the
sense that in procedural memory we have
some kind of propositional thoughts and
propositional structures whereas the
declarative memory the common form of
memory is looked into and the working
memory was a connection between these
externality procedural type of memory so
this was an end to this section on
memory of general information in the
next section was based on defining what
are concepts and categories and so what
why we wanted to study concepts and
categories is because in the earlier
section on semantic memory we saw that
the node consists of concepts and
categories so what does concept concepts
are basically representations of worldly
knowledge so however something is
represented what is the way in which
particular information is represented in
the human brain or human mind is what
concepts are and categories are similar
concepts or things which have
similarities together how they are
clubbed together is what is called
categories so we looked at how
categories and concepts are formed we
also looked at the various nature or
various models of concept for example we
looked at the classical view which says
that how the way in which concepts are
form or how we categorize things
together is in terms of the fact that
the more closely
two things appear together identical
they are clubbed together in a position
to this the prototype view concept in
categorization suppose the suggest that
there is an abstraction which is made
out of it because it
happen that two things may not be
similar but they are clubbed together
for example a bird which doesn't has
feather will will be more of a bird than
any other kind of an animal and so this
kind of violations led to the
proposition or the prototype model which
says that people make abstractions
people when they look into a certain
kind of a concept or certain kind of an
object free people when forming
categories they make abstractions of
what the category element is so from
that prototype they actually go ahead
and then include other members into that
particular category then we came to
something called the the schematic view
an exemplar view in the exemplar view
what we looked at is that these
prototypes that we talked about so
basically what people do is when making
categorization they look at all the
elements which are present in the
category and from that they they create
an abstraction they look at the
commonality and based on the common
oolitic they create an abstraction now
in the prototype view the idea was that
this abstraction may or may not exist in
real life but the exemplar view suggests
that the abstraction that we have made
in the prototype view does exist in real
life so when we think about fruits I am
thinking about a particular fruit maybe
an apple and so this is the exemplar
view it says that when I say the
category fruit the idea that fruit is
something that is eerie that you eat it
has seeds it as a particular taste and
so on and so forth but you also think
about a particular fruit for example in
orange or apple and so on and so forth
and so this is what this particular
concept of exemplar view suggests in
addition to this this chapter also
explained how concepts are really formed
what are the way in which concepts are
formed and so in this we discussed
successful scanning conservative
focusing and some other methods of
forming a concept beside that we also
looked at how people acquire prototypes
and once they acquire prioritize how do
they use to form this kind of a
knowledge system that we have discussed
in the semantic that is useful in
forming and organizing semantic memory
in the eighth week we discussed on to
something called the visual and spatial
nature of memory
and so in this we looked at what is
visual memory so visual memory is mental
imagery it's basically similar to the
fact that when I ask you to think about
something by closing your eyes and when
I ask you to imagine something what do
you imagine so the same kind of thought
the same kind of imagination that you do
is what is called visual memories we
also looked at some mental mnemonics
which are useful which are mental
shortcuts or which are mental aids which
help us in remembering things and some
of the mechanics that we discussed here
where the method of loci the method of
interacting images and the method of
backwards
now what this pneumatics tends to do is
they tend to organize information in
such a way in such a visual manner that
people tend to remember them better and
this remembering them better makes their
memory better or makes better encoding
of their memory in addition to this we
looked at two propeller theories of the
visual memory of how why visual memory
is better than any other kind of memory
and the one method or the one theory was
the dual coding hypothesis and the other
theory was the relational organization
hypothesis where is the dual coding
hypothesis suggests that whenever
something is committed to visual memory
it has two codes and auditory code in a
visual code and since it has two cores
it is better remembered the relational
organization hypothesis say is that if
the better learning is not because of
the fact that any memory which is
committed to visual memory has two codes
it is because of the fact that there is
a relation established between the
number of interacting images and so
number of images if an image is taken
and if two two things have to be
remember two bits are for three bits of
information has to be remembered and if
you make imagine of these three bits of
information and make them interacting
together the interacting image is better
remembered then separate images and so
this is what the theory goes on and says
and then we looked at theories of mental
rotation which basically goes ahead and
says that it is not only that we store
static visual imagery we also are able
to do mental manipulations
rotations from mental images and there
are several theories out there
there are several experiments to prove
that people are able to mentally rotate
an image mentally rotate and particular
information or mental representation in
addition to that we looked at what is
the nature of visual imagery and we
discussed some of the some of these
nature for example the nature of
implicit encoding perceptual equivalence
special equivalence and so on and so
forth and this is where we ended the
section on visual and spatial memory the
next section was about studying language
or understanding what language was and
in this section we started by first
identifying what is language and how it
is different from communication so
language has a particular format it has
a particular grammar it is arbitrary
Nature has a particular structure and
then it can be used to create new
sentences whereas communication is
bounded by certain limits so language
and communication differs in the fact
that communication is restrictive in
what information it can pass but
language is not restrictive because it
has several features which helps us in
to communicating a number of ideas
across a number of people and it is the
universal method of combining two people
or multiple people together we also
looked at the structure of language here
now in the structure of language we
looked at how Western language is nearly
built so we looked at what is the basic
level the phonemes level the morphemes
level the level of the syntax the level
of the semantics the level of the
pragmatics and so on and so forth so at
the funding level at the word level how
information is we looked at the
phonology and phoneme level from there
we motored morphology where the basic
speech sound are combined together to
give the first words and then or the
first sentences and from there we came
up to the level of the syntax which is
how sentences are written in in
particular language for example we
discussed the English language here so
we looked at the grammar or the syntax
so our sentence can be completely
syntactic but it may have no meaning and
so generating meaning out of a sentence
is what is called semantics so semantics
is the study of meaning of a language a
language could have a perfect way or a
perfect syntax which means that it could
be grammatically correct but it could
produce no meaning and so this
production of meaning is what is
semantics from semantics to moved on to
something called pragmatics which is the
social rule of how our language should
be used and so this is what we did in
this section other than that we looked
at how language comprehension happens
and with language comprehension we also
looked at how text comprehension and
sentence comprehension happens now in
language comprehension it is believed
that language unlike text is continuous
in nature and so changing one phoneme
can change some can change something
else so language comprehension is
basically categorical in nature in the
sense that people form categories and
they understand the language which has
been broken since language is not broken
down whereas in text perception what
really happens is that there are
something called circuits and fixations
of the human eye that leads to
perception of text in terms of
processing sentences sentence perception
happens in formal just way so people
read a particular sentence or a
particular paragraph and generate a list
out of it are generated gist out of it
and gist is what is remaining with
people so meaning is or just is what
remains and all other words and meanings
are taken away from it so this is what
the perception Apple when we looked at
several errors in speech production
different different kinds of errors
which can be there and how they are
compensating for language or how they
show what languages is or capable of and
what is or not capable of in the end of
it we looked at something called story
grammars which are basically how stories
are perceived so any story grammar is
basically a way in which a story is made
and how it is read and how the meanings
are generated so story grammars are
basically a structure of any story and
so this ended the section on human
language skills next came the section on
thinking and problem-solving and so in
this particular section we started by
first defining what a problem is
we looked at two different kind of
problems the problems of the ill-defined
and well-defined problem and the routine
and non-routine problems we looked at
both this kind of problems which other
out there and what is the difference
between that we also looked at different
kinds of problems which exist for
example we have the analogue assess the
arrangement problem the divergent
problem the transformational problem the
arrangement problem and the induction
problem and so on and so forth so we
looked at different kind of problems
which could be out there we also looked
at the
approaches to the solution of problem
for example the behavioral approach
where we looked at trial and error is
the reason of how a problem is solved
and we also looked at the gestalt
approach in which it is the phase of
induction and the phase of waiting which
leads to the final answer so a stage
where people just don't do anything and
they wait and that leads to the I
experienced in that gender is the
solution we also look at various
variables which affect problem solving
for example problem representations it
could be mental said functional
fixedness or zero types we can help in
the formation of ill-defined problems or
how what can the errors be there in
problem formation we looked at various
strategies and problem solutions for
example we looked at the algorithmic
strategy we looked at the strategy of
heuristics and we looked at the
means-end strategies so there are
different strategies how a problem can
be solved and at the end of this we
looked at what is creativity what are
different kinds of creativity which is
out there and we looked at two
dimensional view of mapping creativity
next section that we discussed was a
section on reasoning and in this section
we looked at how the reasoning and
decision-making the last two sections
are basically sections in which we
looked at the higher order cognitive
processes up till now up till before
language or till language it was the
basic coronary process which was taking
information from perception sensation
attention memory and they were creating
raw materials from the sections on
thinking when problem-solving reasoning
and decision-making interpretations are
made of these mental representations and
so in reasoning we looked at what is
reasoning so basically reasoning is an
evaluation of conclusion which is given
which is based on a given meaning so we
looked at what is reasoning and how the
reasoning is used or how evaluations are
generated beside that we looked at
different kinds of reasoning so the two
kinds of reasoning which are there which
is called deductive reasoning and
inductive reasoning within the deductive
reasoning we have the syllogistic
reasoning and we have the conditional
reasoning we also looked at inductive
reasoning which is another form of
reasoning how we come from general to
specific so this is the kind of
differences which we looked into we also
addition to that we also looked at
several criticisms of these reasoning
processes in addition to that we also
looked at
what is judgment how does judgment
really work and what is the meaning of
judgment so basically judgment is
reasoning the applied to a given
information for generating a particular
conclusion we looked at several errors
in judgment into this section for
example some of the errors that we
discussed was the error on availability
or Esteve labelled an error on the
representativeness and the anchoring in
what these errors really mean is that
these errors lead to faulty judgments or
lead to inconclusive judgments so
availability heuristic a Houston which
leads to improper judgment which
basically means that we trust people
trust their memory more and based on
that they make the judgments similar to
that the representative curious gives
the fact that since a particular
information a particular line of
omission which is available from memory
since it represents or it it is very
representative to a certain kind of
category people make these kind of
judgment errors and similar to that is
the anchoring in effect or anchoring
error when Indian dition to that there
are several other biases which can
appear in judgment for example the
hindsight bias the bias of illusory
correlations or the by of conjugation
fallacy and several other kind of errors
it's there in the last section we
discussed something called decision
making so this is the last process which
happens after reasoning in a judgment
once reasoning and judgment is there a
number of options are available to
choose from and so this isn't making a
process where we go ahead and look at
the number of options which are
available to us and make a final choice
now whenever we they make this choice
this change is always under certain kind
of risk and certain kind of uncertainty
and so as humans we always wish to make
the best choices which are there and
which is rational so what is the
rational choice the rational choice is
the one which gives you which maximizes
your profit but minimizes your loss and
that is what we tend to do so this is
what our decision making was all about
now we looked at two different ways of
making decisions first was the normative
view where we looked at something called
the expected utility theorem and the
violations of it now in the expected
utility theorem we looked at what is
expected utility and we calculated that
expected you
or the descriptive model of
decision-making suggests that
decision-making has to be made in terms
of what is the utility of particular
option and what is the probability of
that option happening and we looked at
this kind of a calculation and the
option which gives us the maximum
utility and has the maximum probability
of occurrence is the one we select and
we looked at that this is how a rational
decision maker should make the decisions
but with humans enough information is
not available or information is not
available and so there tend to make
irrational choices or irrational
interpretations so what they tend to do
is they trying to do violations of this
expected utility by doing something
called preference reversal or aversion
shifts which basically means that if
they choose an option one in a
particular situation they keep on
reversing or they keep on shifting the
choices in a situation to situation 3
and so on for whereas the expected
utility Theory believes that if option a
is chosen and the condition 1 the say
option should be chosen under n number
of different conditions which stress to
occur and so we looked at some
descriptive theories of decision making
the theory that we looked at is called a
prospect theory which basically says
that the gains and losses which comes
out of a particular decision are mapped
on to different dimensions larger gains
has show smaller increase or smaller
increase in feeling whereas smaller
losses show higher increase in pain and
so losses and gains are interpreted
differently by human beings also the
fact that not only these gains and
losses of how it is the way a particular
game and our particular option is
presented to you whether it is a
nickname frame or a loss frame well
decide what option are you going to
choose from a number of options which
are given to you so given the fact that
a particular option is given to you in a
gain frame people choose your bets but
if something is given to you in a loss
frame people are more risky so people
are more risk aversive in a gain frame
whereas people are more risk prone in a
loss frame beside that we also looked at
something called two phenomenon of
psychological accounting and sunk cost
effect which are basically demonstration
or extensions of what prospect theory
suggests it suggests that people
to throw good money after bad money
which basically means that people value
those options which have taken a large
part of their money and but still are
unenjoyable whereas they do not go for
better options options which have taken
in lesser when you are but are more
enjoyable
similarly when people have to spend on
things which have been assigned a
certain psychological account people
will not like to invest onto those
options
whereas if some particular loss or a
particular gain has not been
psychologically accounted for people
would like to spend more money on to it
the last section
we looked at how effect it interacts
with decision making and what is the
role of effecting decision making and
when they looked at there are two modes
one is the effect mode and the other is
the descriptive mode in the descriptive
mode people more conservative more
people are tend to think in non
effective way and tend to donate more
whereas in the effective mode people
make decisions in terms of how they feel
about it and so they are more
conservative and they are influenced
more by the sweep of or the scope of the
particular effect so this in total is
the number of things that has to be
studied that any course on cognitive
psychology has to happen and as you can
see we started our journey from the
history of community psychology moved on
perception attention then memory several
forms of memory then language thinking
and problem solving this is in making
visual memories and so on and so forth
so this course was an attempt for from
my side to basically introduce you to a
very basic knowledge of cognitive
psychology although cocaine is like oh
this is just an introduction and this is
just the starting point of a cognitive
psychology any course of cognitive
psychology each chapter of this section
can be expanded further and can be
studied further into more basic fields
and once you do a course on cognitive
psychology the other fields that opens
up are cognitive neuroscience or fields
of neuroscience cognitive technology and
so on so on and so forth so the whole
field of cognitive science then opens up
with you because security psychology is
an inherent part of any cognitive
program or brain and behavior program in
any Western University or any University
is out there so I hope that you enjoyed
this whole 12 weeks ride with me
enjoyed each part of it there were
points at which you may not have
understood
you're free to some concepts you are
free to write back to me and consult
with it I'm probably sure that you
enjoyed this whole write for 12 weeks
I'd like to then say a final goodbye to
you and hope you do good in your exams
goodbye and thank you
[Music]
you